the good thing about their drum system
they use very very high quality sound
you can use hero drums with any any type
of music you can play any style with it
at first glance arrow drums might remind
you of an air guitarist imitating his
favorite musicians the drummer victoire
Nordberg actually does create sounds
when he swings his sticks in empty space
arrow drums is a virtual instrument yeah
movin from France is one of the
inventors together with drummer Victor
Norberg he demonstrates the principles
behind it the drumsticks have reflective
tips and they're also reflective markers
on the drummer's feet a high-speed
camera transposes the motions to the
computer program because you capture a
very high speed you have a very accurate
understanding of the trajectory of those
objects and when you air drum you
signify your intent to hit a drum by
stopping your motion sharply so we can
program the computer to detect that
event this comparison with an acoustic
drum set demonstrates the accuracy of
the computer program
but the instrument does have its limits
the thing that I'm missing from our
drums is brushes you know playing with
brushes because you don't have a there's
no surface he alerted to play on it and
you have this sweeping motion of the of
the brushes brushes are seldom used in
pop music they are more typically used
in jazz arrow drums is at home on past
region Liverpool Britain this is a
vibrant district brimming with music
clubs and startups pass Street Studios
once belonged to the band Genesis many
artists including Coldplay have recorded
their world hits here the same building
houses the office of the two-man team of
aero drum we're also near to and our
vehicles of Baltic triangle where
there's a lot of creatives is a setting
up shop our people in graphic design
also in music it's kind of renewal of
Liverpool in this way young mova came up
with the idea for error drums when his
now business partner Richard Lee left
Liverpool and his drum kit to go to
college he lived in a student apartment
in Dublin but wanted to keep drumming
that's what got the ball rolling the
first arrow drum set appeared in 2012
meanwhile drummers all over the world
are using arrow drums 5000 sets have
already been sold and demand has soared
in recent months but what do well the
professional percussionists think about
arrow drums Jim black a jazz drummer
from New York is known for his
unconventional technique and extravagant
sounds
before his performance in Berlin zigzag
Club Jim black tested the virtual
instrument for us backstage you don't
lift up before you hit you let the stick
hit so gravity plays a huge part in this
you'd have to chill you to develop a new
technique in something like that but if
you're onstage with Prince why not you
can totally get away with playing his
drum machine parts on the instrument
like this it would be great in Liverpool
mova and Lee are already working on an
improved version of arrow drums the idea
is that you are wearing VR goggles and
when you plan you look around your kids
it's actually there because in air
drumming currently they'll actually no
object there so this lets you actually
see your drums arrow drums won't spell
the demise of acoustic drums but they
might establish themselves as an
instrument in their own right then
there'll be two kinds of percussionists
drummers and arrow drummers